un hommage à samuel patty est donc
prévue dans les écoles lundi prochain
sous réserve bien évidemment de mesures
prises face au co vide un temps
pédagogique sera organisée dans les
classes pour reparler des faits et pour
réaffirmer les principes républicains
comme la liberté en est la liberté
d'expression dorénavant la question
d'utiliser les caricatures controversées
comme support pédagogique et bien elle
se pose
mais pour le président français du culte
musulman ce n'est pas la bonne solution
alors il faut il montrer les caricatures
à l'école pour expliquer aux élèves la
liberté d'expression elle c'est l'objet
tout de suite de notre face à face et
pour en débattre nous sommes avec rené
chiche professeur de philosophie auteur
de la d instruction nationale aux
éditions ovadia bonsoir à vos côtés
yasser louati président du comité
justice et liberté pour tous messieurs
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france rené chiche
je me tourne vers vous vous êtes
professeur de philosophie au retour des
vacances dans le cas où les écoles
restent ouvertes
qu'allez-vous proposer à vos élèves est
ce que vous allez venir avec des
caricatures de mahomet dans votre
cartable et bien oui évidemment c'est
une évidence je vais venir avec ses
caricatures pour une simple raison c'est
que j'ai un collègue qui a été
atrocement assassinés en raison de ses
caricatures
je n'ai pas du tout l'intention en
revanche de montrer ses caricatures pour
les justifier
d'autant plus que personnellement je les
trouve ces led mais parce que c'est ça
le fait aucun doute dans la mesure où
quelqu un a été tué à cause de ses
dessins il faut absolument que ces
dessins soient montrés c'est un acte de
résistance l'évident bien entendu
je vais pas me contenter de montrer ses
caricatures le vrai sujet abordé par ces
caricatures c'est d'abord c'est le sujet
de la liberté effectivement d'expression
et la liberté d'expression c'est pas
forcément la liberté de dire tout et
n'importe quoi
donc je remettrai les choses en
perspective je pense effectivement qu'il
faut mettre plus en avant que la liberté
d'expression il faut mettre en avant la
liberté de penser et c'est ça qui est en
jeu et c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est un professeur qui a été touchée il
ya à faire là outils selon vous est ce
que comme rené chi vous vous pensez
finalement que ces caricatures sont un
bon support une bonne base pour pour
expliquer la liberté d'expression et le
contexte dans lequel est mort cet
enseignant merci bonsoir
déjà il faut quand même qu'on garde une
certaine cohérence donc cinor de
caricaturer et pour moi qui suis un
radical cette liberté dans ce cas là il
faudrait pouvoir tout caricaturer et pas
seulement les personnes qui ne peuvent
pas répondre dans ce cas là si monsieur
20 chiche
je pense qu'il veut montrer des
caricatures dans ce cas là il faudrait
aussi pouvoir pour aider caricature
par exemple une photographie d'une
personne qui s'essuie les fesses avec le
drapeau français et qui avait remporté
un concours photo en 2010 hees avait
déclenché une hystérie nationale comme
quoi il faudrait légiférer pour
interdire consommant du drapeau français
dans ce cas là si on continue sur la
caricature continuer dans votre logique
monsieur est invité et dieudonné pour
qu'ils viennent se fiche des massacres
et les génocides de la shoah
donc ce n'est pas on se moque des
personnes qui ne peuvent pas répondre
ayant dit voici la libre expression en
même temps comment se fait-il qu'en
france on apprend cette liberté avec le
droit d'insulter son voisin son camarade
de classe sont professeurs ou autre nous
en apprend pas cette liberté avec les
personnes qui apportent des idées qui
font avancer le pays pourquoi pas des
personnes qui ont été et qui ont été par
exemple
convoqué par le renseignement intérieur
pour leur enquête et leurs révélations
donc on peut pas dire nous défendons une
les blés d'expression dans un sens mais
absolument pas dans l'autre il ya même
temps je reprends les propos de jacques
chirac qu'on pourra pas accéder à nice à
mogo schiste bien sûr nous avons tous
une libre expression et me concernant
elle est totale mais seule chose qu'on
devrait interdire les appels à la
violence les appels à la discrimination
ou
la haine point voir maintenant si beau
si on nous dit mme à l'expression c'est
j'ajoutais les musulmans dans ce qu'ils
ont de plus cher mais lorsque mont sacré
est insulté je me révolte et jeudi c'est
inacceptable dans ce cas là on voit bien
qu'il ya un deux poids deux mesures et
que l'argument ne tient absolument pas
la route
on était un dernier point s'il vous
plaît c'est que les chiffres vous
répondra après allez-y merci en même
temps c'est que il faut qu'on garde en
tête on est en train de former des
jeunes élèves en leur disant vous voyez
donc un marin de classe musulmans il a
ce qui est très cher pour lui c'est son
prophète
tu as le droit de le caricaturer et
ensuite on eût dit nous sommes une
nation nous sommes unis nous le vivre
ensemble etc
non il ya un moment j'ai mon droit
d'insulter monsieur la personne qui
parle avant moi mais pas responsabilités
à ses sensibilités je m'en tiendrais
rush qu'est ce que vous vous retournez à
ce que vous venez d'entendre baisse que
je viens entendre notre stern je
voudrais d'abord commencé par dire que
les personnes qui peuvent plus répondre
ce sont celles qui ont été égorgés
décapité
donc maintenant je vous arrête tout mais
monsieur le terrorisme international
on laissera la xbox a en des musulmans
non loin non l'as monaco le gardien on
laisse parler rené d'al qaïda ce sont
des musulmans chacun chacun son tour
dont l'espagne en échec vous répondra
frites vous répondra ensuite
allez-y rené chiche le fait que samuel
pâti ces sources et égorgé par un fou de
l'ariège monde simplement parce qu'ils
avaient été dénoncés par des parents est
complètement hystérique suite suite à un
cours d'éducation morale et civique sûr
sûr sûr sûr la liberté d'expression en
se servant de ses caricatures
ça c'est un fait monsieur on ne peut pas
le nier
donc moi je me place simplement je me
passe dans ce contexte là dans ce
contexte là bon après avoir
tuer des journalistes après avoir égorgé
un prêtre après avoir égorgé un
enseignant e
il ya un minimum de décence à avoir et
cette naissance vous ne l'avez pas vous
ne l'avez pas vous qui n'avez pas la
décence vous vous servez raison des
martyrs pour faire passer une idéologie
nous s'il vous plaît allez chiche vous
permis mais ayez à faire loi dit je vous
promets vous répondez dans trente
secondes vous terminez enrichi vous ne
savez rien de ce que je vais dire j'ai
dit que j'allais les montrer ses
caricatures parce que c'est c'est c'est
le motif c'est le mobile du crime et que
c'est la moindre des choses que je dois
en tant que professeur de france à un
autre professeur de france qui est mort
dans des conditions atroces ça ça ne se
discute même pas et je soutiens pour le
coup complètement le président de la
république qui a dit qu'on continuerait
à montrer des caricatures maintenant
j'ai dit aussi et je le je me répète que
ces caricatures ne me plaisent pas
forcément que je vais pas justifier quoi
que ce soit par l'intermédaire de ces
caricatures jeu simplement il faut
savoir en réalité il faut savoir
respecter dans la religion ce qui est
respectable et critiquer ce qui est
critiquable et je dis bien critiquer et
je suis d'accord sur le fait que des
caricatures ne sont pas une critique
pas plus que les insultes de son
critique les vraies critiques elles ont
été faites par des intellectuels ils ont
fait dans des livres et moraux
effectivement au delà de notre essai
caricature c'est évidemment de faire
lire ses textes et de faire réfléchir
les élèves viennent vous avez répondu
yasser louati dans ce cas-là seriez vous
prêt à caricaturer les services de
renseignement qui ont échoué à protéger
la vie de samuel pâtit bien que nous
avons là la surveillance de masse dans
ce pays
toutes les communications sont
surveillés par l'état les boîtes noires
et ses allées m6 catcheur seriez vous
prêt à montrer des caricatures qui se
fiche du renseignement intérieur qui ont
mis en danger la vie de samuel pâtit
deuxièmement dans ce cas là si quelqu'un
vous dit je veux pouvoir faire visionner
une vidéo de dieudonné
iriez-vous jusque là puisque chacun a
son sacré et que vous dites c'est une
caricature qui nous déplaît je trouve
que
n'est plus marrant du tout j'assume
parfaitement maintenant si une personne
vous dit au nom de ma liberté de pouvoir
me moquer de ce que les gens ont de plus
sacré en l'occurrence ce que le génocide
était juive au 20e siècle
soyez vous prêt à continuer dans la même
logique mais mais c'est pas tout ça la
liberté la liberté ça consiste ni fnac
et vous l'insultez la liste des
musulmans dont il plus cher monsieur
vous pouvez pas me dire le sacré des
musulmans ne compte pas et le sacré des
autres est important également que
sérieusement c'est là qu'on appelle le
vise c'est là que le vivre ensemble et
la responsabilité vis-à-vis des autres
il ya serge moati vous vous propose en
gage que vous concernant les propos des
uns et des autres il y à aussi à un code
un code pénal finalement qui est là et
qui jugent déjà en fonction du code
pénal
ce qui n'excuse que les caricatures ne
prévoit pas ne sont pas pris le match
non monsieur non non vous allez pas me
faire le coup du code pénal et des
personnes qui estiment que les tarifs
d'achat de dieudonné
sinon des personnes estiment que le
caricature de dieudonné sur ce que les
juifs ont pu vivre de tragique est
acceptable
j'estime que non j'estime que ça na pas
être diffusées y'a personne peut vous
demander au nom de cette même logique de
me moquer des autres je voudrais les
regarder maintenant que diriez vous que
dites vous de max angle du drapeau
français qui a été moqué en 2010 et les
personnes qui ont fait gagner le
concours à cette photographie a été
licencié parce que c'était acceptable
mais vous dit absolument n'importe quoi
c'est effrayant n'ont pas les moyens de
sa valeur qu'est ce qui vous pose une
question monsieur s'il vous plaît
messieurs la parole les surallocations
véritablement révoltant vous confondez
toinou et voulait absolument rien à voir
mais vraiment rien à voir on n'est pas
là en train de de dire du mal de la
religion notamment rogner think bouger
le droit d'insulter ce que les gens je
vous dit écoutez vous parler à une
personne qui est un radical cette
liberté pour mot devrait l'interdire
je vous dis seulement cette liberté
donnée qu'elle vit avec une
responsabilité
elle peut pas être à sens unique je vous
dis seulement si des gens vous disent
vous avez le droit d'insulter mais par
décence ne le fait pas pourquoi
continuer à le faire
des personnes estiment que se torcher
avec le drapeau français est
inacceptable jeu
soit mais des personnes peux vous dire
c'est mon rôle c'est brad de faire
laisse moi donc le faire une personne a
gagné un concours photo pour cette
torche et le drapeau français
les deux personnes ont perdu leur emploi
qu'est ce que l'on qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant acceptable ou pas
rené chic vous répondez écoutez
franchement je ne sais même pas de quoi
vous parlez je voudrais simplement dire
que si la recette une hystérie nationale
monsieur en 2010
yacine louati vous laisser répondre
monsieur chiche s'il vous plaît
franchement ces caricatures d'abord ce
sont ces de l'humour premièrement c'est
de l'humour c'est de l'extra pas encore
chez aux attentes mais de l'esprit mais
si vous voulez mais je ne parle pas du
sale on parle pas de ça monsieur je vous
rappelle qu'il ya quelqu'un qui s'est
fait décapiter vous avez encore la tête
sur vos épaules et c'est très drôle ça
vous paraît très drôle mais moi ça vous
coûte votre bêtise que samuel faty ce
soit décapité et que des gens comme vous
se sert de sa mort pour faire passer
leur idéologie
il ya certes il y as her louati ses
propos bien évidemment on n'engage que
vous on va clore ici ce débat en tout
cas merci à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté notre invitation direction ratée
france merci à vous rené chiche rappelle
que vous êtes professeur de philosophie
auteur de la d instruction nationale aux
éditions bayard
merci à vous et yasser louati président
du comité justice et liberté pour tous